hello everyone we're going to make a
react native augmented reality
application with the help of Expo and
the Google poly 3d object library what
our app will do is it will display a
camera to the user and when they click
the plus button they will be able to add
a 3d object in the world and they can
also search for new objects using the
Google poly library so right here I'll
search for duck and we'll grab something
that looks cool and you can swap this
out for a penguin or we can look around
and maybe put the dog in there
all right so the first thing we need to
do is open the expo xde and click create
a new project now I usually choose tab
navigation project even if I'm not
making a tab based application because
it gives you a lot of default files and
folders that I find convenient I'm going
to name our project which I'll call poly
snap and I've already got a folder
picked out on my desktop where I want to
place my application so I'll click
create and this usually takes a couple
of minutes so I'll pause the video and
return when this is finished loading
alright the project is finished creating
and one thing I think is a good idea to
always do as soon as it started is to
run your project on a device or
simulator just to make sure that
everything got created correctly so I'm
going to open the simulator right now
and while that's loading I'm going to
open up my code and any code editor so
just give one second for all of this to
load
all right so I've got my code over here
and the simulator is still launching
while that's running another thing I
want to do is open a terminal window in
the project directory so I'll click that
and that should give us a terminal
window okay and as you can see over here
on the right hand side the simulator has
launched the application there are no
errors everything worked out correctly
so the first thing we want to do in this
terminal window is install a few
packages that we're going to need
eventually throughout the app the first
set of packages we're going to install
have to do it three J S which is a
JavaScript library for rendering
graphics so we'll do NPM install -
capital S for save and we will give it
the three package and expo - three I'll
press ENTER to install those and while
this is installing we'll do a little bit
of cleanup of the code over here like I
said we did a tab navigation project and
it gives you a lot of default stuff but
there's a lot of stuff that we won't
need and so we can just delete it out so
first let's come into the main tab
navigator file and we're going to delete
all the references to the links and the
setting screens so that would be the
file references oops here are the actual
tabs themselves and down here is where
it figures out what icon be used for the
different tabs and I'll clean this up
just a little bit save that then we can
delete the files themselves as they're
not being referenced anymore
and finally we'll come in to the
homescreen and just delete all of this
text out because we aren't going to need
it so right here I'm going to delete
these styles here I'm deleting some
functions that this screen is using that
we don't need and I'm going to delete
everything except for the outermost view
and we did delete the container style so
instead of that why don't we just give
some padding and here we'll put some
text that says homescreen just to make
sure everything's working and we can
also delete a few of these components
here that we won't be using just a
little bit
okay and I'll save it the app will
refresh I'm going to check on the
installation packages looks like it
installed correctly and we want to
install one more package which is expo
graphics so we'll type NPM install -
capital S for save and Expo graphics and
this will give us a component in Expo
that we can use to render graphics so
while that installs I'll minimize that
and as you can see on the simulator
we've got the home screen showing up
showing up here so a few more cleanup
things I want to do I always delete the
layout file out of constants because I
never use it and in the components
directory I always create OOP I usually
delete this styled text file and I
always create a folder we got an error
over here because we deleted the styled
text and it's being referenced right
here so I'll just delete that and that's
what I need the web browser so delete
all of that and save and we can reload
it should work and I always create a new
folder called app components and inside
of that create a file called index J s
which is where we'll reference all of
our components that we create throughout
the app one last thing we can do since
we're not actually going to be making a
tab application is coming to our main
tab navigator and switch this from a tab
navigator to a stack navigator
so let's import the stack navigator also
from react to navigation and just change
this to be a stack navigator
and here are the options that it was
giving to the tab navigator since we
have now a stack navigator we won't need
those options but we may add some other
options as we build the app we'll have
to wait and find out and I'll save this
and as you can see the tab went away so
I think we're ready to start actually
building the application
okay now we're ready to add the camera
to our application so I've got my home
screen open and over on the right side
I've got my actual iPhone streaming the
reason for that is because you can't use
the camera and a simulator so you need
to use an actual device in the home
screen we're going to import a few
components first let's import Expo from
Expo and then we will import Expo three
and three from Expo three and we'll also
export import Expo graphics from Expo
graphics and you should recognize these
as the packages that we installed when
we first created the application now
down here instead of rendering the text
home screen we're going to return an
expo graphics dot view which is what the
component that allows us to use the
device's camera and gives us some
augmented reality capabilities so let's
give it a style of flex one and we need
to set a few properties on this to get
it working the first one is on context
create and this is just a function that
gets called as soon as the graphics
context is created so let's assign that
to this that on context to create which
is a function that we haven't defined
yet but we'll do in just a second we
also need to set the on render function
which is a function that gets called
every time the graphics scene is
rendered so we'll save this on render
and finally to enable it for augmented
reality we need to set a are enabled
equal to true I'll come up here and add
our functions on context create we're
going to make that an async function and
it takes quite a few arguments one of
them is geo which is the reference to
the graphics takes scale width height
and the AR session information on render
takes a single argument called delta
which is the time difference since the
last time the render method was called
so let's save that and make sure we
don't get any errors
it's reloading over here on my phone
well that's loading you need to do a few
things to get the the three J s scene
setup you need to basically have a
renderer a scene and a camera and so
we'll do that in the on context create
so first let's put a little comment that
says initialize renderer and we're going
to create a variable called this
renderer and we're going to set it equal
to an expo 3 dot create renderer and
what that does is it takes a GL context
and gives you a renderer back we also
need to set the pixel ratio to the scale
and that just helped us with some sizing
constraints and you also need to set the
size itself with the given width and
height if you don't call these last two
things it'll look a little bit weird
okay next we should initialize the scene
we'll put a comment there that that's
what we're doing and we're going to
create this dot C and that's going to be
equal to a new three dot seed and we
want to set the background of the scene
to the actual augmented reality session
which is the camera with whatever types
of graphics we put inside of it so we'll
say this equals Expo three dot create a
our background texture and we give it
the AR session as well as the renderer
that we just created and finally we need
to initialize our camera so we'll say
this initialize camera and we'll create
a variable called this camera that
equals expo three dot create a our
camera and that also takes the AR
session and some of these scaling
arguments you can just copy this I don't
actually fully understand what it does
but there's some documentation on three
J s's website that explains what these
numbers all mean
and finally in our render method all we
want to do now is say this render dot
render and we give it the scene and the
camera if we save that and run it we
should have an AR session running in our
application I'll test it in just a
second all right so I'll hold this up
you can see there's my desk and this is
looking through the camera of my phone
so we have the camera and everything
working we've also got a whole bunch of
errors down here in this these yellow
boxes and they're a little obnoxious so
I'm gonna show you how to get rid of
them temporarily sometimes you do want
those boxes on there because they can
give you some useful information but in
this case there's not much we can do
about a lot of these so if we just set
console disable yellow box equal to true
then those boxes will no longer appear
and let's just run and double check and
it's nice to have them not on there
because we'll be looking into the camera
a lot and they just obscure the view all
right so holding it up again and as you
can see there's no more yellow boxes
now we're going to investigate the
Google Pali API which is an API we'll be
using to get 3d object information for
our app this is an API provided by
Google and you can find the
documentation on developers.google.com
slash pali first thing you need to do is
click this button right here to get an
api key so go ahead and click that and
get your api key and then jump back over
to your code and let's go into the
constants directory and we will create a
new file called api keys dot j s and
inside of this we will put all of our
API keys so we'll export default and
create your object here and let's create
a property called Google Pali and put
whatever API key you created in this
string right here alright I've just
added my API key and remember to keep
your API keys a secret so that other
people can't use them since we're not
going to be using the app for a little
while while we do this I'm going to go
ahead and close my preview of the app
right here and let's jump back over to
the Google Pali documentation so it
gives us access to 3d objects it'll give
us all the 3d object files that we need
to render them in our augmented reality
app and also give us some screenshots
and a few a little bit other information
that we might find useful if we come
down here to guides we can click Pali
API and get some more information about
it the API as it says here allows you to
list assets list your assets or get a
specific asset well we want to do is use
the list assets API because if we're
going to allow users to search for
different assets and then we'll display
whatever they've chosen so just a quick
overview of this here's the request that
you use for the API and here are some
parameters you can
you can give it keywords which is
probably will we'll be using for the
search you can specify certain
categories like animals or technology
you can specify a format if you want
only a specific type of 3d object format
page size controls how many results you
get back from each search and then page
token is a way to have different pages
of data so if we say that our page size
is 10 and there's a total of 100 results
of that search we would need to use the
page token to get page two and page
three and so on down here it gives you
an example of what the response will
look like we'll look at this a little
bit more deeply in just a second but the
documentation here is pretty good and it
would be wise of you to take a look at
it
another thing you can do is use the
Google API is Explorer right here and if
you look up the Pali API you can
actually test out API calls so we're
using the list API so I'll click that
and here we can just type in any kind of
search parameters that we want so for
keywords we could look up duck and click
let's set our page size to be 5 and
we'll click execute and it'll actually
run this API call and down here it gives
you an example of what the results would
look like it also shows you what the
request itself would look like we would
just call get on this URL except replace
this with our API key and as you can see
down here we get an array of assets and
each asset as a display name and author
a description some information about
what is created and then this formats
array actually has the 3d object files
so there's a dot obj a material file
here's some additional files and
different formats
all right so let's go back over to our
code I'll make this a little bit larger
so we have some more room and what I
want to do is go into the API folder and
create a file called Google Poly dot J s
and here we're going to build out a
little sample a little class for working
with the Google Poly API so let's do
explore default class Google poly and
let's create a constructor and the
constructor is going to take the API key
so whenever we create a new instance of
this class we'll give it the API key and
then we'll store it in a property called
this dot API key and that allows you to
use it if you have a secondary API here
you want to use it in a separate project
with a different API key next thing I
want to do is create a function called
get query URL and what that's going to
do is take an API key and a few other
parameters that we decide we want to use
and it will return us the URL to perform
the query and the URL would be something
like this so why don't we actually just
copy this and paste it into our code and
we can look at it as a reference while
we're building this out I also want to
make this a static function since we're
passing in the API key and it doesn't
need any access to any member variables
at least I don't think it will all right
so let's create a variable here called
base URL and it's gonna be this this
portion of the URL that never changes no
matter what the parameters are so we'll
set that and then we're going to build
out a URL based on the different
parameters that we want to give it so as
a review here are all the parameters
that are possible and for our
application we're going to let users
search using a free text search box and
whatever they type in we'll just put
into the keywords parameter and
show them those results so let's make a
new variable called URL and that's going
to be equal to the base URL plus key
equals and I'm getting this from here it
doesn't matter what order you put the
parameters and I always start with the
API key so I don't forget it so put key
equals that plus the API key that we
were given in the function and I'll say
URL plus equal which adds onto the URL
and parameters should be separated with
an ampersand you can also use query
parameter building libraries if you want
but this one will be simple enough that
I don't really mind doing it myself so
let's take a look at our parameter
options I think for this app we want to
set a page size so that we don't load
too many all at one time so let's just
hard code our page size to 10 and back
over here it's got this max complexity
parameter which is an enum and it takes
medium simple or complex let's let's
hard code it to medium so that we don't
get too complicated graphics and and
overload our application so we'll set a
person and max complexity equals medium
the other thing I want to hard-code is
the format of the results that we get I
only I want to limit these results to
obj files the other formats could
potentially work but I'm only familiar
with OBJ's and so I only want to give
users options that have an obj file
format so we'll set ampersand format
equals obj and let's see we also want to
add the key words so let's pass in key
words into our function will say
ampersand key words equals and since the
key words will come from user input you
need to make sure that you clean that
input and don't allow any sort of unsafe
characters to get in so the way you can
do that is by calling in code you are I
component and giving it the past in
parameter and since we're going to
support multiple pages we also want to
pass in a next page token but this one
will be optional since the first very
first page won't have an X page token so
we'll say if next page token is passed
in then we're going to add that to our
URL and I believe the parameter is is
called page token so we'll say ampersand
page token equals and next page token
and finally we will return the URL so
this function should give us a query URL
with a given API key keywords and an
optional next page token and another
thing I just thought of just to be safe
if the keywords for some reason we're
blank we probably don't want to say
keywords equals blank so why don't we
put this around a in if statement as
well so we'll say if keywords are passed
in the
we will add the keywords to that
parameter all right now I want to make
another function that actually gets the
results so why don't we call it get
search results and this will take a
keywords parameter and a next page token
this one's not I don't want to make this
one static so in that case we'll have
access to this debt API key but we'll
still need keywords in next page tokens
so we can build our query URL and what
those functions going to do is it's
going to build the query URL and then
call the API and return the results so
let's first get the URL so we'll call
the static function via Google Poly dot
get query URL and the first argument is
API key which we have right here as this
API key
the next two are keywords and next page
token so now we have the query URL that
we need to use and since just a basic
get request which you can tell from the
API Explorer right here we can just use
fetch to get the results so we'll call
fetch we'll say return fetch give it the
URL and you need to usually do these
kind of thing where you convert it to
JSON so I'll say then dot then function
response will return response JSON and
then another dot then which has the data
itself and what we want to do with the
data is take a look at the data that
we're given and it gives gives us an
array called assets let's see if it
gives us anything else if we scroll all
the way down to the bottom it's also got
a next page token and a total size which
I think is the total number of results I
think for this function all we want to
do is return the array of assets and
later on we'll come back and grab the
next page token
and figure out how to handle our
pagination so we don't want to return
the whole data we only want to return
data assets and since we're handling
this with promises the way we should do
that as return promise dot resolve data
assets so now when we call this we can
use the normal promise syntax and we'll
be given the data assets so that should
be enough for us to test it out so let's
go back to our home screen and we want
to import Google Poly from it was an API
slash Google Poly remember we need to go
up one level because we're currently in
the screens folder now let's create a
constructor here remember you always
need to call super props and let's
create an instance of the Google Poly
API class that we just made so I'll say
this dive Google Poly equals new Google
Poly and we need to pass in the API key
which we have in our constants slash API
keys file which we also need import so
right here will import API keys from dot
dot slash constants slash API keys now
back down here we'll call API keys
Google Pali and we'll save that and
let's check the expo window right here
when we do console dot log some messages
will appear down here that we can take a
look at so I'll make this a little bit
smaller again
now that we've initialized our Google
poly object we can call this Google poly
dot get search results which is the
function we just created and remember it
takes a keywords and an optional next
page token parameter so for our keywords
we will give it duck and next page token
since we don't have one because of the
first page we will pass in a blank and
then we could say dot then function and
remember it's giving us the assets and
inside of here we should have our assets
let's just double check by doing a
consult out log assets and if we refresh
and I think I may need to run it on my
phone so just one second yeah it closed
out so I'm gonna scan it on my phone and
all that's gonna do is load the app
which should go straight to the home
screen which will call our home home
screen constructor it'll generate the
Google poly object call get search
results and give us the assets and I've
just realized that I made a typo if I
come back over here it's saying that I
spoke keywords wrong so here it is okay
I accidentally misspelled keywords right
here so I need to fix that and rerun it
okay so the simulator has launched and
as you can see over here it's it tells
me that it can't run OpenGL and
simulator that's what we expected but
all we really care about is the console
and as you can see right here it has
printed out a bunch of JSON data which
is the data from the API call and if you
don't believe me just does a double
check I'll pull this over here and I'll
reload the application by using the
command plus R button it's going to
relaunch and here we go here is all of
our asset data
look
one thing that we're going to do that I
think would be convenient is let's take
a single asset and copy that data into a
file so we can use that as a reference
as we're building the app and we don't
have to constantly be calling the API so
there's a few ways we can do that the
way that I want to do it is just grab an
asset here we'll just say assets zero
and we'll call we'll create a variable
called JSON and we'll say json stringify
and we give it the first asset and what
that's going to do is take this asset
and convert it to a JSON string and then
we're just going to display that string
in the console and we'll just from the
console copy and paste it somewhere so
I'll save this I'm gonna clear my
console here and as you can see we've
got that JSON data and a big string so
we'll just copy this and why don't we
put this in our assets folder so we'll
come into asset so you've got fonts and
images let's create a new file called I
mean shoot a new folder called objects
and since we were searching for ducks
I'll assume that the first asset was a
duck so let's create a new file called
duck object dot JSON and inside of here
we'll paste that string and I'm sure
there's a way to format it automatically
for you and this code editor but I don't
know how to do it so I'm just going to
put a few break line breaks in here not
for the whole string but just so we can
look at a few things in here there's
another property called thumbnail
somewhere in here there it is that now
we can kind of read this and I think the
data that we really need is thumbnail
formats and probably the display name
and the author name and it says turkey
day happy turkey day
hashtag turkey so this object may
actually be a turkey so why don't we
just renamed it to turkey object
Jason all right so just as a way of
checking that our object is working
properly and that we got all the data we
wanted let's try to display the
thumbnail as an image in our app so if
we come over here we can see that the
turkey has a property called thumbnail
let me just pull this over here and the
thumbnail object actually has a few
properties ones called relative paths
one is called URL and one is called
content type format some of the stuff
too so I think all we need to do is grab
the URL out of the thumbnail property
and that should be in a format that we
can display in an image let's come back
over to our home screen and let's import
turkey object from assets slash objects
slash turkey object JSON that should
give us access to the turkey object data
save that save that and down here in our
render method temporarily we will
comment out the expo graphics view and
instead will return a normal view with a
flex one and inside of here we will put
an image and let's double check that we
have image in our imports we don't so we
need to import an image from react
native so we can use it and image takes
a source property with a URI property
and the URI and our case will be turkey
object thumbnail URL and keep in mind
that came from here's the object we want
to get the thumbnail URL property and we
also need to set a width and height so
let's give it a style will say width of
150 and height of 150 and let's save
that and
hopefully we won't have any errors and
there you go there's our thumbnail this
is what the 3d object should look like
it's not the 3d object itself it's just
a thumbnail or screenshot but this is
what we can expect once we've loaded the
3d model so let's comment this out in
case we want to use it later and
uncomment this section so we can go back
to having our camera
all right well we're going to do now is
allow users to search for any kind of 3d
object they'd like rather than having
the turkey hard-coded em as you can see
I'm running the simulator over here on
the right because we won't be needing
the camera for a while so in the home
screen I'm going to come down to the
render function and just temporarily
we're going to add a view where we can
do some experimenting with our UI and
once we're happy with the UI we will
integrate that into the entire app so
I'm just going to return a blank view
we'll give it a style with some padding
on top and save that and make sure we
don't get any errors since we're using
us we're going to have a search
component we're going to need a text
input to allow users to type in the
search that they'd like to do so up in
our imports we will import text input
from react native and back down here in
our render method let's add a text input
and let's also add a button that allows
them to perform the search so the title
of the button will be search and on
press will be this dot on search press
and that the text input will give a
value equal to this dot state dot search
query and unchanged text we will say
this dot on search changed text and
we'll need to implement these functions
now so let's add them right here on
search change text we'll take a text as
an input and we'll just call this dot
set state and we'll set search query
equal to the text that we're given and
the on search press function will look
like this but we'll implement this and
just a second we also want to go ahead
and add search query to our state so
let's scroll up to the constructor here
and we don't have a state yet so we'll
say this state equals and it'll give it
a property called search query which
starts off as a blank while we're here
we can go ahead and delete this code as
we don't need it anymore and save and
reload
all right the text input is a little bit
difficult to see so let's give it some
style and we'll add a little border
around it
so let's add a new line here say style
equals border width of 1 and also add a
placeholder that says search let's also
adds set the height to 40 okay so we've
got a search box here and a search
button it doesn't look great but we'll
make it look a little nicer later on now
what we want to do is let's create a
component for displaying our results so
if you remember down here we had this
image of the turkey object let's put
that in here and take a look at it again
and it looks pretty nice but I think we
also want to add the author name and the
display name of the object and whenever
the user searches for something will
show a table filled with these objects
which shows the image and the author's
name it's important to add the author's
name because the objects are licensed
under a Creative Commons and you need to
give attribution to the author and the
display name is good just so people
might have a better idea of what the
actual object is alright so let's come
over to our components folder and open
up app components and let's create a new
file will call this Google poly assets
yes and we're going to create a new
component so let's import react from
react I'm going to import view text and
image we might need a few light a few
more later well we know we need an image
to display the thumbnail and some text
to display the author name and the
display name and a view to hold
everything so let me spell import
correctly and from reacts native and
then we will export default class Google
poly asset which extends a react
component and it's going to need a
render method which we will just return
a view for now
fill that in later but first let's come
into index j s and let's import google
Poly asset from google Poly asset and
then export google Poly acids alright
now we can access google Poly at asset
and other files save that and in our
home screen we will import Google Poly
asset come down here import Google Poly
asset from components /f components save
that reload now our Google Poly asset
will take as a property the asset object
so let's make a default props object and
we'll say asset which we will initialize
to a blank object and that's kind of a
reminder that this needs to take an
asset as a property in our render method
now we will return a view and inside of
this view we'll put off the thumbnail
and text stuff that we need for the
asset let's flip back to the home screen
and scroll down to our image right here
and just copy and paste this so we don't
need to retype it and we'll put this in
our view and instead of source being the
turkey object thumbnail that URL it's
not going to be the property asset that
we pass in so we'll say this stuff props
assets that thumbnail that URL and if we
wanted we could move these styles into a
stylesheet so why don't we go ahead and
do that now we will import a style sheet
from react native and down here will
stay constant style is equals style
sheet dot create and we'll say thumbnail
has a width of 150 and a height of 150
and we'll just delete these styles out
and instead say styles mm now save that
now why don't we try using the Google
Poly asset instead of this image right
here to make sure that it's working so
we'll add a Google poly asset and the
asset will be Turkey object so if we did
everything correctly we should see the
same thing on the screen once we delete
this but it'll now be inside of our
Google poly asset component rather than
the image and we have an error here so
let's double check I think the air is
that we didn't put this in brackets when
we imported it so should import it
correctly and there you go there's our
thumbnail of our turkey now one thing I
wanted to do with this is I wanted to
round off the corners just a little bit
I think it would look a little nicer and
the way you can do that is by setting a
border radius
let's give it a border radius of 10 and
see how that looks okay looks pretty
good and we can add some padding on the
side later if we want to let's just go
ahead and add the display name and the
author name down here so we'll just add
some text components that one we'll put
the display name and here we'll put the
author name let's give them each a style
called styles that display name and
styles got authored in come down here
and the display name and author name and
I think what I would like is for the
display name to be bold and the author
name to be normal so but font weight is
old and we don't need to put anything in
author name because by default it would
be normal so let's go back to our turkey
object JSON reference and figure out
what the property names aren't they're
just called display name and author
names so we should be able to just add
in this
this props dot asset display name make
sure to put it in brackets and this
stuff props dot asset author name and if
we say that we should now see our text
below the image great let's also put a
style on our view called styles
container and let's also align our text
using the text align property to be in
the center and maybe that's not how we
do it maybe we need to put a line items
here Center okay so everything centered
there we can delete that alright so now
we've got a component we can use to
display our search results it'll look
like this and actually we want to do one
last thing I think what I'd like to do
is have users be able to click on the
asset so let's add a touchable opacity
import from react native and let's
surround the whole thing instead of a
view we'll surround it with a touchable
opacity and touchable opacities need an
on press property so if we're on press
will say this dot crop stat on press and
in our default props we will initialize
on press to be a function that doesn't
do anything and this serves as both a
reminder that you should pass in on
press property and it helps to prevent
crashes in case somebody forgets the on
press property when it tries to call
this it'll just call a function that
doesn't do anything rather than crashing
so let's save it and try clicking on it
as you can see the opacity changes so it
gives the user an indication that it was
clicked on so that should be all we need
to display our search results
alright let's return to our Google poly
class we were working on earlier and
make a few adjustments to it that can
make the searching process a little bit
more convenient for us I'll switch over
here this was the function get three
model that we were working on to get the
3d model which will collapse now because
we would be working with that and as a
quick summary we have two functions in
our class one called get query URL which
just gives us the URL that we can use to
Pat to call the API and get search
results which takes key words and a next
page token and returns us the results of
the API and the form of the promise when
users click search they're going to be
given the first page of data which for
us will be ten results because we've
hard-coded our page size to be ten I
also want a button down at the bottom
called load more which when they press
will load the next ten results using our
next page token and what I'm going to do
for my application is just concatenate
all of the results into one big array
and show them all as many times as they
click load more that may not be ideal
for your application you may only want
to show ten results at a time or twenty
or however many and implement some sort
of pagination scheme so feel free to
make modifications as you need for your
application since I'm going to have all
the results in one big array it makes
sense to keep track of that array in our
class so I'm going to add a new property
called this current results which I'm
going to initialize to a blank array I'm
also going to track the next page token
as a member variable and I'm also going
to track the keywords as a member
variable so instead of get search
results taking in key words and a next
page token we're actually going to pull
it from the member variables here so
we'll say this key words and this next
page token and down here when we
received the results instead of
returning them as a promise we're going
to append them to our current results
array so the way that we can do that is
setting this current results
equal to this current results.com cat
data assets and that will concatenate
the results of the API to our current
array let's also set our next page token
to the next page token that we're given
which is data dot next page token and we
can actually keep our promise here to
return the results of this specific call
if we want and so users will be able to
get the next 10 results from this
promise or they can get all the results
by just calling their instance of Google
Pali current results now we need a way
to set the keywords so that when get
search results is called it actually has
some keywords so let's make a new
function right here called set search
params and it will take one input of
keywords and what this function will
when it will be called is whenever the
user clicks search so if the user types
in turkey and click search what we
wanted to do is clear out all the
existing results all of the existing
next page token stuff and sort over with
a brand new search of turkey so we're
going to do set this current results
equal to a blank array so any results
that were already in there wiped out
this time next page token it's going to
be set to blank and this dot keywords is
set to the input keywords so how the UI
is going to work is the user will type
in their search result here their search
query here they'll click search which
will call set search params and reset
all of our member variables then it will
call get search results which is going
to search based on the keywords that are
given and the next page token which for
the first page will be blank that's
going to call the API grab our results
and append them to our current results
array which is currently blank it's
going to set our next page token and
it'll return a promise with the assets
for just that query then if the user was
unsatisfied with the first
results they can click the load more
button which we haven't added yet and it
will call get search results again which
will run the query append the next ten
results to our current results array set
the next page token and return the
results 11 through 20 so let's save that
and give it a shot all right so let's
flip over to our home screen and try to
implement the new changes to the API in
our UI so we talked about having a load
war button so why don't we go ahead and
add that let's come down here to where
we've got our search button let's add
another button called load more and when
it's pressed it will call this dot
onload more press which we need to
implement so we'll say on load more
press and we've now got two buttons that
we need to implement so as we said when
search press when search is pressed
we're going to grab the text out of the
search box and call set search params so
let's get the text which is equal to
this state dot search query instead of
calling a text one we call it keywords
and we'll say this Google poly which is
our instance of the Google of poly class
dot set search params and we'll give it
keywords so now we have set our search
brands we've wiped out any results that
may have already been there and set our
keywords now we want to actually call
get search results so we'll say this
Google poly dot get search results takes
no inputs now but it returns a promise
so say bat in function with assets and
we can do whatever we want with our
assets here
but I think what we're going to do is
instead of get using these assets we're
going to use this Google poly dot
current results I'm just going to have
all the results of every query that we
run
so let's come up to our constructor and
let's add a new state parameter called
current results which is initialized to
a blank array and whenever the query
returns we're going to set state that
current results to the Google poly
current results and setting the State
will trigger a rerender with the new
results so up here we're going to say
this set state current results is going
to be equal to this Google poly current
results and since we're referencing this
inside of a function we need to bind the
this context so I had bind this right
here okay and load more press should do
almost the exact same thing except it
won't reset our keywords or our search
parameters because we want to keep those
the same but it will call get search
results to get the next page worth of
data so let's just copy and paste that
down here you could factor this out into
a separate function if you'd like I
don't think it's necessary in this
particular case let's add a console dot
log here with our assets just to make
sure that we're actually getting data
and before we test it out we do need to
make one slight change back in our
Google poly class again since we're
referencing this inside of a function
here we need to bind the this context by
calling dot bind with this otherwise we
wouldn't be able to access the stack
current results or this next page token
so let's save and try out our new search
open up the expo xde and we'll type in
turkey do a search and as you can see
there are some results and if we click
load more I believe we got some more
results so that's just a quick check to
make sure that there aren't any huge
errors let's now actually display the
results on the screen all right so back
in our home screen to display the
results we're just going to display a
Google poly asset for every asset in our
estate that current results so one way
we can do that is by using a loop or we
can also use the map function so let's
make a function right here called render
current results and what this is going
to do is we'll use the map function to
map all of our current results to a
Google poly asset component so we'll say
return this state that current results
dot map now take a function with an
asset and an index and we will return a
Google poly asset whose asset property
is equal to the asset that we're
currently mapping and since we're going
to have multiple of these we need to set
a key otherwise you'll get a yellow box
error and we'll just set the key equal
to the index and instead of displaying
our turkey object we're going to call
this render current results and when we
make a small modification here which is
we'll we'll check the length of this
death state that current results will
say if this state that current results
dot length equals zero then we're just
going to return text that says no
results that way we know that we don't
have any results and if there are
results in there we'll call our map
function
let's save that and I just realized that
we didn't call the function here so add
the parentheses there and call it save
it again okay so we've got no results
let's search for turkey and click search
and there you have it we have our
results and I'm unable to scroll so we
need to change this to a scroll view to
allow scrolling save it again and try it
one more time click search and there you
go we have a list of 10 results related
to turkeys if you take a look at the
last one it's dis bird with the red head
let's load more and make sure that we
got 10 more okay so that was our
previous last one in here 10 more
turkeys actually it's only 3 so that
must have been the end of the results
for turkey let's try changing the
results again to dog and click search
and well the first two results are foxes
and and that's one thing I've noticed is
this the keywords query gives you some
sometimes unexpected results as you can
see there's a lot of animals on here
that are actually dogs I'm not really
sure what's going on with that but the
API is working correctly it's just kind
of giving you strange results
all right so let's try to make our
search results look a little bit nicer
we'll probably come back to this later
on and clean it up a bit but we can do a
couple of things right now for one I
think we can actually fit two results
per row and I also would like to move
the load more button down to the bottom
so when you've scrolled down here you
can click load more right there other
than having to scroll back up and we may
make a couple of modifications to the
text input so let's start off with
adding two results per row and to make
things a little bit easier for us since
we may be refreshing and researching
over and over again
let's initialize our search query to be
turkey so that every time we reload we
don't have to type in a search query and
click search we've got turkey right
there we can go ahead and click search
and get our results all right so to get
to per row we're going to update our
render current results function we still
want the no results text if we have no
results but let's try to put that in the
center instead so let's add a view here
and I'll say Styles Flex one aligned
items Center and into the view so now
the text will look a little bit nicer
when there are no results and down here
instead of using the map function let's
create an array all the results will put
all of our Google Poly assets let's do a
loop for bar I equals 0 eyes less than
this dad state that current results dot
length and I plus plus what this is
going to do is it's going to grab two
results at a time put them into a view
with a flex direction of row and and
show all those results so first thing we
should do is we should check if we're on
the very last result and we don't have
an extra one then we don't want to try
to add two so let's check if are equal
if I equals this state that current
results data length minus one then we're
just going to return a Google of Poly
asset whose asset is now equal to this
dead state that current results I and
whose key is now I and will break from
the function but if we're not on the
last one which means we do have at least
one more we can I'm sorry this should
not be returned this should be results
dot push because we're adding to the
results array and then down here after
the loop we're going to return our
results like that I'll just delete the
map function right there okay so now in
this section of code we know that we've
got at least one more result so we'll
say results dot push and in this case
we're going to push a view which has a
style of Flex Direction row inside of
that view we're going to have to Google
poly assets one for the current result
one for the next result so say I here
and I plus 1 I plus one and since we're
looking at two results at a time we want
to change our loop to be I plus equals
two instead of going up by one each
iteration will go up by two each
iteration that should be all let's save
and take a look at what our results look
like now
one thing I do want to do is turn off
the disabled yellow box feature so that
if we do get any errors we'll see them
let's refresh and we'll click search to
get our search results and we are still
getting this key error but we are
getting two results per page it looks
like so let's figure out what's wrong
with this err
first I believe it's because the view
doesn't have a key
so let's set the key here equal to let's
say row plus I okay we've limited the
air we've got two results per row but we
want to Center these a little bit and
maybe add some padding in between them
so to Center them let's put our results
into a view so we'll say return view
with the style Flex one and aligned
items Center and inside of that view we
will put our results get rid of that and
to add some padding in between these
we'll go into the Google Poly asset
component and in our container style
let's just add some padding of about ten
so save that save our home screen may
have to refresh again and click search
and there you go we've got some padding
in between rows two results per row
everything was looking good there so
we'll collapse this because it looks
good right now and we said we're gonna
put the load more button towards the
bottom that's easy to do we'll just cut
this and paste it right below the
results and if we click search we've got
our results with a load more button down
here and for some reason it's getting
cut off at the end so why don't we just
add a few here with some padding on the
top just to give us some extra space so
we can see everything and click search
load more great now something I just
noticed is we're getting a load more
button even if we don't have any results
and I actually would like to hide that
button until we have some initial
results so any way to do that is with
the ternary operator let's take our load
more button and put it into brackets and
give us some space here and what we'll
do is we'll say if this state that
current results length equals zero
we're just going to show a blank of you
but if it's not zero we're going to show
the load more button so I'll save and
refresh that now we're not getting the
load more button once we have our
initial results we've got a load more
button there and we have some padding
down below now for one last UI change
let's let's update our text and put a
little bit and make it look a little
nicer so I'll come to the text input
here we've already got some properties I
want to set the auto capitalize equal to
false actually I think it takes off
string so let's set it to none and for
the style I want to add some padding
some margin on the horizontal of 10
let's refresh and see how that looks ok
so it added a little bit of spacing here
and let's also give it a border radius
of 10 to round off the edges and I don't
like how close the text is to the end of
the box so we'll also add some padding
horizontal of 10 as well
now we're ready to display the object
that the user actually selects on the
screen rather than the turkey as you can
see I'm now streaming my actual device
because we're going to need the camera
and I've once again disabled yellow
boxes by uncommenting this line because
they were getting in the way of the
button so just as a quick test I'm going
to try adding a turkey again to make
sure everything was working properly and
there you have it I clicked add turkey
and we got a turkey added right there so
in order to keep track of the users
selection we're going to add a new state
variable and we'll call this one current
asset that's going to be the 3d asset
that the user has currently selected and
rather than defaulting this to an empty
object not only defaulted to the turkey
object so that way before the user has
even done a search they'll have an
object that they can add to their screen
I'm also going to delete these two state
properties because we recently extracted
them into the searchable Google poly
asset list I'll save that and we need to
set our current assets whenever it is
chosen from the search menu so if we
come down here this is where our
searchable Google poly asset list is and
we need some way for this component to
tell us when an asset has been chosen
and if you recall on our when we created
the Google poly asset component we gave
it a non press function so we can
utilize that to determine when the asset
has been pressed so what's coming to our
searchable Google poly asset list
component let's make a new property and
this one will be called on asset press
and we'll initialize that to a function
that doesn't do anything let's scroll
down to our render current results
function and called the on asset press
function anytime an asset is pressed
open this up and here's where we're
adding our Google poly assets let's
format the text just a little bit add
some line breaks in there to make it a
little bit easier to see when these
properties start getting pretty long
oops and we want to implement the on
press function for the Google poly asset
and we want to call this dot props dot
on asset press but we run into a problem
which is this is running in a loop and
we need to know exactly which asset was
pressed so why don't we come up here and
why don't we add an asset here to
indicate that this function will take an
asset and we'll come back into our
Google poly asset function and the on
press will also provide us with an asset
and when the on press is pressed here
what it's actually going to do is call
this dot props dot on press and it's
going to give it this props dot asset
so whenever a Google poly asset is
pressed it's going to call its on press
function and give this asset object
right here as an input so I'll save that
and come back into our searchable Google
poly asset list now I need to implement
the on press for the other Google poly
assets that we've added let's add a few
line breaks here to make it a little
easier to read
and put on press here and on press here
let's save that alright as you recall
we're currently adding the object in the
on add turkey press button and we're
assigning the object to a variable
called this turkey since it won't always
be a turkey I think we should rename our
function and our object so why don't we
name the variable to this three model
equals object and let's check where
that's being used I think it's being
used and on render this is where we're
rotating it so instead of this turkey
we'll say this dot three model and
instead of on add Turkey press why don't
we say on add object press and come down
here and instead of saying add Turkey
will say add object and call on add
object press and in the Google Poly dot
get three model function call instead of
passing in turkey object well we're
actually going to do is pass an the
current asset which will say this dot
state current asset and since we
initialize it to the turkey object we
can be sure that it will always have
some sort of object in it I'm going to
delete this console dialog that says
adding Turkey because we're no longer
adding a turkey and let's review when we
click add object it will call this and
it will load the asset that we currently
have and actually one thing that we need
to do is whenever this is pressed we
need to remove the current object so one
way of doing that is by saying this
scene dot remove and we want to remove
this dot three model so you can only
have one three model on the scene at a
time and we'll check if this actually
exists
so if this dot three model
then we will remove it so that way if
they click add object and it adds a
turkey and then they go and search for
something else and click add object
again it'll first remove that turkey and
then add the new object that they want
to add
let's also close the Moodle anytime an
asset is chosen from the search so we'll
come down to our on asset press function
in the home screen and after setting the
asset we're also going to set state
search modal visible equal to false so
let's save this and test it out all
right so I'll hold my phone up and press
add object which should give us the
turkey by default if we looked around a
little bit there's the turkey now let's
do a search and have always searched for
duck and there's the turkey we don't use
that how about we take this penguin and
if we click add object you could see the
turkey goes away and the penguin gets
loaded in
now that the main portions of the app
are just about complete we're going to
do a little bit of cleanup to make it
look a little nicer and the cleanup will
be done in no particular order so let's
begin let's move over to the home screen
and the first thing I want to do is make
these buttons down here at the bottom
look a little bit nicer so I'm going to
use icons instead of buttons and we can
use the icon library that comes with
Expo or you can install the library it's
called react native vector icons so we
will import material community icons as
icon from react native vector icons and
we'll come down to our render method and
instead of these buttons we're going to
place an absolutely positioned view on
the bottom so out of you here and give
it a style so this view is going to be
position:absolute and it will have a
bottom of zero so that it appears on the
bottom also going to add flex one flex
direction of row and that should be it
for this one let's also add a sub view
this one will also say is flex one flex
direction row and we'll set the justify
content to space between so they will
have all of our buttons spaced out now
for the buttons we're going to use icons
the icon library comes with the
component also called icon button and
you give it the name of an icon and an
on press events so we'll have this
button be our ad object button
so we'll say on press equals this step
on ad object press and we'll look up the
name later we'll add another one
call for our search button so this will
call this step on search modal press and
I actually want to add one more button
that we haven't implemented yet which
will be called remove object and that's
just going to remove the current object
if you don't have one on there so Save
icon dot button name is blank for now
and the unpress
remove object press let's go ahead and
implement the on remove object press
let's scroll up and here's our on app
add object press will put it right below
that on remove object press and we've
actually already done the logic for that
here so why don't we copy that paste it
and instead of doing this will just say
this tap on remove object press alright
let's save that and refresh and as you
can see we've got three placeholders for
icon buttons but we don't have any
actual icons because I left a names
blank they've also got blue backgrounds
which we don't want so let's go ahead
and add a background color of
transparent for each of these copy that
and paste it here and to figure out the
icon names we can go over to the
material community icons websites and
for add object I think we'll use a plus
sign so let's search for plus and see if
we can find one there's one and the name
is just called plus we'll put the plus
here or we could use the plus box
outline potentially let's look up - for
the remove and so add - for this one
maybe we'll just use the plain ones and
then for the search let's look for a
magnifying glass if
type search there's a magnifying glass
in the name of it is magnified so we'll
type that in and save it and see how it
looks and you can barely see them
because they're white but they should be
a little more visible once we've removed
these buttons and we might make them a
bit bigger as well so we can go ahead
and delete these buttons now since we've
implemented them as icon buttons let's
save again and there we have it we can
test these out I'm going to click the
magnifying glass button and as you can
see our search box comes up okay so
let's just go ahead and make these icons
slightly bit larger so we'll set the
size equal to and say let's try 30 and
see how that looks and when I make it
about 40 I think would be good so I set
all these to 40 all right
and that looks pretty good nice big
buttons should be easy to press try it
out okay if I click Add four add an
object let me get our turkey perfect
next I'm just going to scan through some
of the files we made and I'm going to
delete any debugging code that we may
have added I'm also going to add
comments since I've been dictating the
code I didn't really add any comments as
I was going but it's a good idea to add
comments preferably while you're writing
the code but if you have to you can go
back and add them at the end as I'm
doing now I usually like to put comments
on top of each function explaining what
it does sometimes it's pretty obvious so
maybe I'll leave them out for this video
so I'm scanning through here I want to
find any time where we do a console dot
log and we don't actually want to log
something so in this case we're just
logging the foreign asset States I'm
going to comment here remove the current
object and then this one will be add the
current object check out some of these
white spaces this is or rotate the
object render that all looks good okay
so this file looks pretty good I just
collapse everything okay and remember we
can take this out one other thing we can
go ahead and delete this because we're
no longer using that we're just only
using the searchable Google polyester
list I'll save that and I'll jump into
the Google Poly class that we created
just some blank lines here that we can
remove this one I'll say it returns a
three dot J s object
this one returns the results of the
current query sets current search
parameters and resets number variables
this one returns a query URL based on
the given data okay that one looks good
let's go to Google poly asset j/s i'm
through this don't really see any
problems with this one so we'll keep
that same and then our searchable Google
poly asset list look through this real
quick
okay everything looks pretty good to me
and this one so we'll keep that the same
as well all right so now let's work on
the search page component a little bit
and make this look a little bit nicer I
think one thing I want to do is put the
cancel button up here to the right of
the text input and maybe let's put a
magnifying glass icon next to the search
placeholder text so to get the icon we
need to also import the icon library so
that's important material community
icons as icon from react native vector
icons and we'll scroll down to where
we're rendering the search input and
instead of just returning a text input
let's return a view that will contain
the text input so why don't we go ahead
and just call this Styles dot search
container and come down to our style
sheet and create a search container and
what we want that to do is have a flex
of one a flex direction of row and set a
line items to Center so the magnifying
glass will line up and I'm going to
collapse these so I can find where we're
working at easier okay so inside of this
view we're going to add our icon with a
name magnify let's give it a color of
some kind of gray so let's say D D D D
and size we'll say it's 20 and right
next to that we're going to take our
text input
and put it right there and since these
styles are a little long we'll cut these
and instead put styles dot search text
and codes come down to our style sheet
and search text influence okay so we'll
save that and see how it looks
well that's loading I'm going to
reformat these okay so as we can see the
text input is not stretching all the way
to the end like we want it to so we can
fix that by adding flex of one and also
I want the border to be around both the
magnifying glass and the text input I'm
going to take the border width and put
that up here and I'm going to take the
border radius and put that up here as
well and we want to add a little bit of
horizontal spacing between the edge of
the screen so on the container I'll add
a margin horizontal of 10 and I'm going
to remove the margin horizontal from
here so that the search won't be so far
away from the magnifying glass save that
and see how that looks
okay it's looking much better I think we
should change the color of the border
maybe so
on the container will set border color
also to have that gray that we've been
using and let's go ahead and move the
cancel button up to the right side of
the text input as well so let me
collapse more of this stuff and we're
going to grab the cancel button which I
believe is right here take this out and
we're going to put it well we don't want
it to be inside of the border so we need
to put it below the view which has the
border and then we'll have to wrap all
of this inside of another view and this
view should also have a flex of one and
a flex direction of row save that and
see how it looks okay it perfect and
we'll set this to align items Center
just to be safe and I think for this one
we'll want to put the margin horizontal
to 10 and take it away from this one
okay so it's looking pretty good I can
test the cancel button so when I click
that the search page goes away all right
now it's just some of the spacing of the
magnifying glass and the search so I'll
come down here and I think instead of
having a padding horizontal on the text
input we'll add the horizontal padding
to the icon itself so that way it's
spaces out a little bit away from the
edge there and we'll have the same
spacing there so on our icon I think we
can give it a style and I'll say padding
horizontal 10 okay it's looking better
although I still think there's too much
space here so let's change this padding
horizontal to be padding the left of 10
and love of padding right let's just try
three and see how that looks
well that's loading another thing I
wanted to change was the no results text
if we don't have any results I wanna
make that a little bit bigger and make
it italicized so that's an render
current results and here's the style for
our text when we call this Styles dot no
results text and we'll come down here
make a new style called no results text
I'm going to make it a little bit bigger
so I'll say font size up eighteen
font-style:italic
and why don't we put some padding on the
top of about 50 so it has some more
space away from the search button save
that I spelled italic ROM so okay it's
looking pretty good in my opinion I
think one final thing we'll do is we'll
make it so that when you press ENTER on
your keyboard it will automatically
perform the search and I can't remember
the name of the property but I can come
over to the documentation and if we scan
through some of these properties we'll
probably find it I believe it's on
submit editing so this is says it's a
callback that's called on the text and
put submit button is pressed so in our
text input up here we're going to say on
submit editing and we're going to give
it the function that happens when search
is pressed which is the step on search
press say this dot on search press and
let's test that out if we wanted we
could also change our keyboard type to
be maybe web search although that's iOS
only or we'll just keep the default okay
so if I open this up and I search for
dog and I'm gonna press return on the
keyboard and there we have it it's
showing the results now one thing I've
noticed just now is that this text isn't
centered and I think earlier we tried to
make it centered so let's figure out
what's going on there I'll open up
Google Blahyi asset and look at our
Styles we may just need to add a text
align of
Center to each of these save it and see
if that's the problem well that worked
for the first one oh I see I I
accidentally put this in the thumbnail
class should have been in the author
name class okay one last time I'll
search for dog and it looks like all the
text is centered and you trying to click
that okay perfect
all right and there's a bug I want a fix
which is when we search for something
such as dog we get the results and if we
cancel the search and then bring it back
up the results are no longer there but
we have the load more button and I
believe the problem for this is that
we're not correctly initializing our
current results array which is in our
state which you'll find a constructor so
instead of initializing it to a blank
array I think we should set it to this
probable poly dot current results I'll
save that and test it out so I'll do a
search for dog and I've got my results
cancel and bring this back up and the
results are there right load let's try
loading more it's like we have some
layout issues for longer strings of text
okay I'll cancel that bring it back up
and there are the full results and let's
try changing our result to duct there we
go
and another layout issue with long text
to fix that layout issue in our Google
Pali assets we'll come over to the
Google poly asset component and we'll
set a width constraint on our text
components we'll set the width to be the
same width as the thumbnail so here and
our display name will set a width of 150
and for author name also with the 150
and refresh the app I'll do that same
search for duck if we scroll down as you
can see now the text is on multiple
lines rather than pushing things over